[Музика]
привіт, Дженніфер
, до вечора.  немає зайвої скриньки ні у нас
є маркер підходить на поділитися добре 2
motion Chicago do Ritsuko hotel в
дії Вестерос з Такоми б'є амудха
груди поні
привіт дорогі учні мене звати Ольга
Магма я вчитель англійської, ласкаво
просимо на сьогоднішній урок у нас дуже  спеціальний
гість
Марта і Чак привіт привіт Марта
співачка і артистка, приємно познайомитися з тобою
так приємно познайомитися також як справи
сьогодні Марта я думаю добре, я прокинувся дуже
рано вранці, але я в порядку дуже
добре,
ласкаво просимо на сьогоднішній  урок, про який ми будемо
говорити, спробуйте вгадати, якщо ви подивитеся
на картинку про космос, гм, наука
каже у вивченні Всесвіту,
Всесвіт, тому ми маємо картину
Всесвіту, що ми маємо у Всесвіті,
що перше, що ви бачите, коли  ти
подивись на цю картину я бачу я здається, що я бачу
зірки, але я думаю, що це не історія
так, так, зірки, планети і
всі космічні об'єкти, тому у Всесвіті
всесвіт є місцем, де ми залишимо все,
що навколо нас, а ви частина
т  він всесвіт, звичайно,
добре класна кімната є частиною всесвіту
все так, дуже добре, ми
будемо говорити про різні види
науки,
повірте мені, це буде дуже цікаво, я
думав, що я не великий шанувальник науки, але
я  я дізнався, щоб ви позбулися
цього уроку, що наука – це все, що
нас оточує, а наука – це те, що ми робимо
щодня добре давайте почнемо
чудово наука має три основні галузі, чи можу
я попросити вас прочитати їх, будь ласка,
так впевнено, формально й природно будь-які ідеї,
що це таке  про
соціальне це про наше соціальне життя в минулому
я не знав, що це таке, хм, і природно,
це про природу, але земля я думаю,
чудово думаю думаю о, я люблю тебе думаю
так добре дуже добре соціальні науки тут у
нас є об'єкт дослідження
як  Ви згадали, що це соціальне суспільство,
тому простір проти мирного суспільства
дуже хороший, тому воно зосереджено насамперед на
вивченні історії та культури людей,
правильно, ви вчений, я думаю,
так що ви працюєте в сфері соціальних
наука так, тому що ви зі
світу культури так, дуже добре,
дивлячись на картинку, ви здогадуєтеся, що це
все про людей Суспільство мм-хм добре, але
це журнал під назвою суспільствознавці
давайте подивимося, що
входять науки довгий список так,
давайте прочитаємо  це разом
я прочитаю спочатку, а потім ви повторите
гарна археологія археологія бізнес-
адміністрування бізнес-адміністрування
комунікація спілкування економіка
економіка освіта
політологія політологія психологія
психологія психологія психологія це
складне слово у нас є P ми ніколи не
читали дуже гарна історія історія більше закон
і уряд уряд ще одне хитро
слово,
ми маємо додатковий кінець, але ми говоримо уряд
уряд так, і це слово психологія
відмінно молодці, молодці, якщо я
повернуся сюди, чи не згадаєте ви будь-яку з
наук із цього списку ах так
археологія урядова психологія
економіка економіка так бізнес
так  Бізнес-адміністрування політична
політична я  Я хочу сказати, що це
політична бізнес-наука, дуже
добре, тому це лише соціальні
науки
добре  чи готові ми рухатися далі, я думаю, так
добре, тому першим був який тип
соціального суспільства, давайте перейдемо до вгадування,
що це буде з соціальних
наук археологія археологія історія археології,
мабуть, так, дуже добре, що це було
б, що це було б добре  подивіться, ми
говоримо про різні країни, у нас
є прапор Європейського Союзу, у нас є
політика корони так, добре, газова політика,
дуже добре, що б це було так,
бізнес-адміністрування моя племінниця.
і
це було б
чудово  Коли нам довелося
розглянути три перші, ви сказали, що це та,
в якій ви не впевнені, так
добре, тому формальні науки об’єктом
дослідження є системи так, сигнальні системи,
це стосується властивостей формальних
систем, заснованих на визначеннях і правилах,
давайте  подивіться на науки,
які тут включені, це була б
математика гарна наступна
лінгвістика лінгвістика наступна
статистика статистика логіка логіка
теорія інформації теорія інформації так що
це все про ознаки, це не для мене,
це все про логіку, це все про
логіку так, дуже  хороші формальні науки,
давайте подивимося на малюнки та спробуємо
вгадати, що це таке, боже мій, боже мій,
що б це не сказати про мене, я
можу сказати, що я педагог, але якби я
вивчав мову, як вона працює, як
вона працює  whistie так
лінгвістика лінгвістика дуже добре що
щодо цієї
математики так ви добре з математикою ні
не добре, тому ми можемо бути хорошими в чомусь
то в чому ви вмієте я хороший
співаю, мабуть, можливо, у письмовій формі я в
якомусь будинку адвокат так гуманітарна
хвилинка Аріан мм-хм, але не з
математики не математика я був
до того, як я був до якоїсь складної
математики, коли це починалося в 10 або 11
класах так добре, правильно
математика  хороші системи чітка
статистика так, коли ми збираємо
інформацію, ми аналізуємо інформацію
дуже добре, а як щодо цієї однієї логіки
так логіки о, зарозумілості логіки правильно,
а тепер ми переходимо до третього
типу, що було першим соціальним,
другим термо так, зараз  ми переходимо до
природного розміру природи, що ви можете сказати
на малюнку так, це океанська
хвиля чи морська хвиля так, це красиво,
дивіться, що тут, у Природничих науках, наше
об'єктивне дослідження - це світ природи,
але мені подобається, як це визначається  намагається
зрозуміти світ природи всі
інші вчені відкривають його я
впевнений щодо роману, але тут він
намагається зрозуміти, мені дуже подобається, як це
сумно про світ природи, так можна  Ви
здогадуєтеся, які науки будуть включені
сюди все про Землю про
її природу про її природу, можливо, навіть космос це
цікаво, і я погоджуюся з тим, що він
намагається тільки вибір, ми не можемо зрозуміти це
абсолютно природа для мене магія,
наприклад, це дуже складно повне
складно так, це було б гарним словом
для світу
синонімом до слова складно, тому це не
важко, це складно так Клод
NIMH очно
так, дуже добре, так що це природничі
науки,
дозвольте мені прочитати їх заново добре хімія
хімія біологія фізика
фізика медицина медицина інженерія
інженерія  наука про навколишнє середовище Наука про
довкілля дуже
добре перша складна, де це була
хімія, тому що зазвичай бачить H
означає Чу, тому багато студентів читали б це
неправильно  складність так так envira
екологічна так довкілля психічне
середовище  хто і хімія, біологія
і все про пілінг, ліки,
ліки, так маси, які
носили гамбургери, і тепер ми остаточно вирішили,
які три соціальні
формальні природні молодці так,
давайте подивимося на фотографії та газ, добре, це
медицина, добре зроблено, що можна  це
буде дослідження про наше тіло про
біологію рослин так, дуже гарна хімія,
хімія,
це може бути довкілля, навколишнє середовище,
навколишнє середовище, так, так,
науки про навколишнє середовище, це також може бути
Медісон, так, або екологічні
дослідження так.
із зображення
добре, так показуйте формально, як природне, добре зроблено
молодець
Мені подобається переглядати, чим більше ви повторюєте те,
що ви пам'ятаєте, це так, правильно,
давайте подивимося на об'єкти і
спробуємо вгадати, до якого типу науки вони
належать мм-хм правильно  коли ти дивишся на
що перше, на що ти звертаєш
увагу на betcha так, тому
що я використовую його так гідрогелеві пов'язки для очей від
pa  tches куди б вони належали я думаю, що
це гм
медицина, можливо мм-хм, є природне
так добре де вивчається природа
так
біологія добре це дуже добре
все добре дуже добре думаю я хотів би
, щоб ви сказали це дуже правильно думаю думаю
так добре зроблено  Ну, думаю, think
yes Inc, до речі, дуже добре, хороший
спосіб навчитися вимовляти цей
найскладніший звук для всіх відомих
динаміків - це мати дзеркало перед
вами так і просто практикуйтеся, не
бійтеся перебільшувати, робіть це  занадто багато робити
це самостійно в кімнаті буде добре
подумати дуже добре, що наступний
об'єкт мм, що нагадує мені якийсь
журнал так книга так книга
я думаю, що це історія, щоб суспільство
культура була соціалістична так, це може
бути історія  і, ймовірно, археологія дуже
хороша археологія наступне, що ви бачите
гроші гроші гроші
так добре, так, насправді ми маємо два
об'єкти, які будуть належати одному так
[музика]
не може зробити формальним так формальним, але
це стосується культури, це  це як ми заробляємо
гроші як ми купуємо речі як суспільство,
тому що це те, що суспільство робить
добре, тому немає логіки і грошей немає
соціальних так дуже добре, тому що суспільство
має справу з грошима без суспільства ви
знаєте, що немає економіки дуже добре
дуже добре  який наступний об'єкт цей
прекрасний чоловік так статуя так
перського короля мм-хм
де він належав це історія чи
археологія так соціальне соціальне дуже добре
хм що нам залишилося жінці так
так дуже добре
це медицина так
добре  чи це належало б, так це
природно, я знаю, але люди створили людське
захоплення, це настільки формально, знаю, чого ви думаєте,
я не знаю, так впевнений, я думаю, що це не може бути
довго, це може бути з усіх цих типів
дуже добре, але коли ми мали  подивитись у
вашій іншій презентації, що ліки та
фармацевтика були за своєю природою.
а  велика колекція вдома о, так
, ти любиш крики, мені подобається бачити, я
боюся, я трохи боюся глибини, так,
але мені дуже подобається вода, тому це
природно, це третя третя третя третій
тип дуже добре Мені сподобалося, як ти  зробив
слово, як ви створили прекрасне слово
deepness, чи можу я написати його та проаналізувати
для всіх, щоб у нас був глибокий так,
який є прикметником глибокий, і ви додали
дуже гарний суфікс Ness deepness,
щоб перетворити дієслово на красивий
іменник yes deepness what  про щасливе чи
можемо ми зробити те ж саме зі щастям
так щастям так чи сумним так
дуже дякую це було добре глибоко дуже
добре так що ти трохи боїшся глибини
мені подобається те, що багато, але коли я не
відчуваю землі під  мої ноги я починаю
боятися починаю
боятися боятися боятися боятися все
добре молодець у мене є спеціальне завдання, перегляд зараз
добре, давайте перевіримо її пам'ять Марта, у вас
є три типи і у вас є всі
ці почуття мм-хм  спробуйте зрозуміти,
чи  re це належить,
якщо ви не впевнені, де це місце,
живіть це добре, ми повернемося,
це завжди важливо, коли у вас є
доступ і можливість перевірити, чи
ви були праві, будь ласка, поверніться,
перевірте свою пам'ять так добре, дуже добре,
я  цікавить так,
тож це три типи, і
це всі ваші органи чуття, чи можете ви згрупувати їх,
будь ласка,
добре, так що покажіть колишній і природний добре
уряд мама нахабний уряд
уряд уряд уряд
уряд уряд знає, якщо я не
впевнений, я не впевнений, що таке  уряд
уряд політика так так так хмм ні
соціальне дуже добре економіка економіка
так соціальне є ро нама дитина
економіка економіка комунікація
наскільки я пам'ятаю це також партнери про
суспільство
так місце розташування хімія добре хімія
хімія формально не природно так він
вивчає природу одиниці  так добре
моя улюблена наука про навколишнє середовище так
це точно не наука так
математика це природна математика
математика логіка так  нормально формально так,
тому що мова йде про логіку
теорія інформації я не пам'ятаю
теорія інформації звісно так добре
лінгвістика призначте знаки так так
так ви маєте рацію так так медицина
природний хороший закон соча дуже добре
бізнес-адміністрування
соціальне так освіта соціальне дуже добре
фізика  фізика макро математика
фізика ах формально так деякі з них
могли б йти в обидві сторони
наука я не можу бути так так логіка це
формальна ммм-хмм історія соціальна так
так точно так ладно біологія природна так
так інженерна інженерія інженерна
політика наука соціальна так і
психологія  психологія, це формальна
так психологія, тому що йдеться про
суспільство про те, як люди думають, як
люди поводяться з людьми ключове слово люди
соціальний соціальний о так, принаймні ммм-хм,
а екологія також соціальна дуже добре,
тому що вона вивчає культуру та
історію, тому більшість наук  у нас
є суспільствознавство
так Марта, коли я слухав, як ти
думав, чи належить до цих знаків
перша друга або третя група, яку я
бачив, ви вагалися щодо фізики,
наприклад, так, дозвольте мені сказати вам, що
науки можуть бути двох типів чистих і
прикладних, коли ми говоримо, що Мюір це все
належить до досліджень, ви знаєте всі
лабораторії та дослідження ммм  -Хм, коли ми говоримо
прикладне, це те, що потім
впроваджується в життя правильно, щоб
фізика могла вивчати так, фізика може
вивчати Жандро, це може бути чистим
у формі о так, і це може бути природно,
а потім це прикладна наука, так
у нас сьогодні для вас є близько 20 нових слів
так добре, і уявіть, що учні дотримуються 11
в школі, вони мають величезну кількість
інформації з усіх предметів, і вони
повинні класифікувати це, вони повинні
пам'ятати це, вони повинні проаналізувати це
зазвичай я працюю з розумом  карти чи знаєте ви
, що таке інтелект-карти, я можу лише здогадуватися,
що це за правильно, ви можете сказати мені гарне
мапування Монтеня або карти розуму дуже
корисні, це дуже корисна техніка, яка
допомагає вам справді зосередитися на ключовий
роботі  ds, давайте спробуємо зробити це разом, тож
якою була тема сьогоднішнього уроку. Одне
слово наука, наука, правильно, давайте помістимо це
в середину науки мм-хм, скільки
галузей науки ми говорили про
три типи, три, а потім між
цими трьома, які ми мали  різні інші, будь ласка,
давайте разом створимо їх карту розуму добре,
давайте подивимося, наскільки ви пам'ятаєте добре,
що буде першим
соціальним формальним природним правом, а потім я
хотів би, щоб ви записали три
науки, які належали
кожній групі добре так добре, ви готові
так так давайте  зроби це зараз я буду твоїм
студентом добре, тому перший був соціальний
хороший гормон і природний хм, я
люблю писати це добре добре, так що перший
був добре
археологія так археологія О, ти б
хотів, щоб я напишу це для тебе археологія
а я  спробую гарну йогіологію так
ну добре друга я пам'ятаю
історію давайте напишемо складну одну
психологію до першого так моя екологія
rmal
hmm математика так автоматика добре
добре
ви можете перевірити мене так так так, мої галочки
так дуже добре, добре зроблено
математика, а як щодо логіки логіки
логіки і по-третє, коли ми збираємо дані
та аналізуємо їх, можливо, так
статистика D так
T так, сер, дуже добре, тому спочатку  Я виправляю,
чому вони медицину,
C ні дуже хороша друга, це може бути
фізика, тому що так, я пам'ятаю, ми переїхали
так, дуже добре,
а третій, один третій, робить його
складним у вогні, боже мій, добре
середовище, о, я можу тобі допомогти  з
орфографією добре, допоможіть мені так en e і VI -
це о, і тепер це розумово, так,
так, екологічна наука е-а-а, зачекайте
, це поширена помилка так
добре зроблено, тепер ви самі створили цю
карту розуму, як ви себе почуваєте, я
думаю  Я відчуваю себе трохи краще на
початку в кінці уроку
добре так, це легше бути чесним,
легше запам'ятати, коли ви пишете його
самостійно, і коли ви поміщаєте його в
групи, він є там, так, уявіть, що це була
сторінка повного  l текст із великою кількістю
словникового запасу, тоді ви заплутаєтеся,
коли його згруповано, ви побачите ключові слова,
а потім ваша зорова пам’ять працює
краще або що так, дякую, дякую
правильно, ми не тільки вивчили багато нової
лексики, у нас є складнощі  справа
з правописом так іноді англійська мова
дивна, ви просто повинні пам'ятати, і
єдиний спосіб - це використовувати
слово багато разів два слова, на які ви звернули
увагу, були уряд і
екологія так дуже добре давайте
напишемо слово уряд у нас є мовчазний
лист  мовчазний лист
просто запам'ятайте, проведіть слово і подивіться, що
воно тут мм-хм так уряд ми не
так ми не вимовляємо його, але ми завжди
пишемо його уряд і що було
інше слово екологія дуже добре
екологічна у нас є ще одна
тиха вода  за словом психологія
як би ти запам'ятав, як це написати
зараз я пам'ятаю це, тому що я пам'ятаю,
що перша літера була піком він перш
за все ти побачив це
так, а потім так, коли ти перейшов  e до
дошки ви це написали, тому подивіться це напишіть це
і поверніться до цього пізніше дуже добре так,
як ми це зробимо так так H сторона
так я називаю мрію так психологію так я
називаю психологію психологія молодець,
молодець і з  звичайно, сьогодні я впевнений, що
ви оволоділи цим звуком я думаю, я
думаю, я думаю, о, дякую, дякую,
дякую, дуже дякую всім
за сьогоднішній урок Сподіваюся, нікому не
здасться, що це складно наука весела, чи
не дуже добре  це справді дякую, що
дуже
дякую, дуже дякую, я був би радий
бачити вас на наступному уроці, сподіваюся, так добре,
дякую всім, будь ласка, пам'ятайте, що
легко впорядкувати свій словниковий запас
на карті розуму,
я впевнена, що Марта впорається  карти розуму
її ключового словникового запасу, безперечно, дякую,
і пам'ятайте, що наука може бути веселою, дивіться
наші наступні уроки, щоб дізнатися більше про
науку та технології, до побачення, Йосаку
Лі Уоллес, гриб — дати esto
nos dejó de nition edenia або наступне
класичне зображення  не є неминучим  Іспанський
кедр або C CE OS, знаючи
лексичний приклад Томаса, і через
машину Стенлі Alicia Keys Navarro Rock
Pro добре,
щоб повторити стрічку, ми можемо зробити цю кімнату,
в якій це естетично.
тому ми бачимо, що ключові
мутації супервихователі статичні coup
de piel свідок не зміни
[Музика]
ви